the international community cannot
condemn the afghan people to collective
punishment and starvation
because they failed in their mission in
afghanistan
that has been our message
and from our part again we if we hadn't
taken the measures that we have taken
and mitigated the effects of this
humanitarian catastrophe that is taking
place here in afghanistan i think we
would have been in a far far worse place
at this moment i'm wondering how long
can you go on
if no country in the world recognizes
your administration as a legitimate one
i mean
how how is that possible how is that
sustainable and don't you have
an obligation almost a moral duty
under islam under any god
to step away if
by you staying it is condemning
millions of your fellow men and women to
a miserable future
just as you rightly pointed out
the
situation the humanitarian situation in
afghanistan the underlying causes are
three that were also pointed out and
highlighted by miss deborah lyons the
the chief of unema here the united
nations mission in afghanistan
she said one
three underlying causes one was the
dependence of of the previous
administration on foreign aid on foreign
assistance
the second was
the underdevelopment of basic
infrastructure the lack of focus on it
on building infrastructure
for sustainable growth and
sustainability self-reliance here in
afghanistan and the third cause
the underlying cause of this tragedy
is recognition of the government
so again
if we look at all three
causes of
of of the humanitarian issue is not
from our side
it is more related to the international
community there's the moral obligation
of the international community
to recognize the government that exists
which is a reality it is not going
anywhere anytime soon
and this government
uh has shown that it is a responsible
actor
uh
so
the the politicizing of recognition
is only endangering the lives of the
common people
well the international community says
you have to show you've changed rather
than just say you've changed right and
the u.s special representative for
afghanistan who i'm sure you know very
well thomas west says recognition
depends on the way you behave towards
afghan citizens
right at the very first news conference
you were there
acting as the the translator after
taking power the taliban's official
spokesperson gave quite a few
reassurances
about women about media about insisting
there'd be no revenge attacks about an
inclusive government
but none of that has happened has it i
think all of them have happened
how has it happened with women women are
still largely excluded from work they've
been told what they can and cannot wear
they've been banned from education
beyond the age of 12. they've been told
they must have a male relative to
chaperone them on on long trips and this
obviously will restrict their movement
and freedoms
that's hard that's hardly the image of
women walking shoulder to shoulder which
was the phrase that he he used at the
time the taliban spokesman employment no
female worker that worked in the
government has been fired from a job
every single
female worker of the administration
is still in her job their jobs have been
they're coming to work has been
suspended their jobs have they have not
been fired from the jobs they are being
paid their salaries that's a very new
point isn't it because if they're not
doing their job and they're not getting
paid for it because many of
public service workers are not getting
paid how is that a job so they're not
doing it and they're not getting paid
how is that a job no they are getting
paid and they do retain their jobs
but they're not doing it the suspension
is because this is an islamic society
and we're working on methods on
mechanisms of how to best integrate them
back into their jobs
it is not because we do not want them to
work shoulder to shoulder
with their fellow afghans
that is not the problem
even if we take the government jobs to
one side millions millions more women
who do other jobs who run their own
businesses or have done and now can't
who were the only bread winners in their
in their family and now their families
don't have anything to
to to to buy to to feed themselves with
so first i uh i answered the difficult
question for you about the government
the private sector there are absolutely
zero restrictions on women working
they are working in banks they're
working in running their businesses
they are doing the all the jobs that
they previously held there have been
absolutely zero restrictions
on the private sector from outside
that is number two
number three in education on the on the
ground that's just not what we're being
told or even seeing
it it's sort of in a way it i'm not sure
you could say that there are no
restrictions but on the ground the women
definitely feel there are
so what do you think the gulf in in this
is
if every person i'm speaking to tells me
something different to what you're
saying why is that
uh
i don't know what the fear
is i absolutely do not know why i do not
understand any of the fear do you do not
understand why they might be fearful no
i i absolutely do not
for schooling
again
if
if we look at the schooling
private schools from primary all the way
to university levels they're open for
girls and women
i don't and you you're fond in saying
because i've heard previous interviews
you've given that education is is
available to all but that's simply not
the case on the ground as far as we're
seeing it and either we're being
confronted by a whole load of afghan
people from all different parts of
afghan society politicians
you know workers rich people poor people
who are spinning us massive lies or
there is some truth in that
again
girls not going to school
in their personal capacity
or due to fear whether rational or
irrational
is their own personal
prerogative
we from our side
the policy of the government
has been very clear
there are absolutely no restrictions on
any girls or women attending schools
from primary all the way to higher
education
but we've spoken to teachers who've been
threatened for
for teaching
so how does that figure who've been
visited by
armed taliban
fighters who appear to be from
the administration or acting on behalf
of the administration telling them that
they should not be teaching
older girls or for instance teaching
them art classes
uh uh uh this is the first time i've
ever heard this i've never seen any
reports do you think it could be true
it possibly could be this is a very
conservative society our security forces
from policy
and from what i've seen and from what
i'm seeing myself with my own two eyes
while living here in afghanistan is that
our security do not approach
women specifically because this is an
afghan society we have a lot of respect
for women we do not threaten women ever
okay can i show you
a video of a young woman
who
appeared on social media
it is
a young woman who took part in a
demonstration demanding the rights her
more better rights
um
yes yeah i've seen it absolutely quite
well known in afghanistan right now yes
yes uh she's saying help help the
taliban are at my door
um we're here on my own with my three
sisters yes or all women yes i've seen
them she looks and sounds
quite terrified yes
she took part in a small demonstration
of about 20 or 30 women it looked from
the pictures
um demanding more rides
she was not alone in being visited a
female being visited by taliban fighters
we spoke to a woman today who wasn't
even at the demonstration but her
daughters were she was in the house with
children
when she says 20 about 20 armed taliban
soldiers
fighters
came into her room came into her house
she tried to stop them coming in saying
that they were children
she's got bruises on her arm trying to
stop the dog being
pushed in by all these
men with with
with um guns i
you're a man so maybe you might not un
appreciate but as a woman
that must be utterly terrifying i'm sure
it must be terrifying if you're a man
how is that showing respect to women
does this mean that you you don't have
control over all your taliban fighters
that video is uh of course distressing
and the incident that you've said is
also horrific if it has taken place
however if you could
if she could lodge a complaint
as per law
against whoever
the intruders were
this was from the ministry of interior
she went she'd been to the ministry of
interior
and complained with the investigation
unit because they took away her mobile
phone and her daughter's mobile phones
and she said i'm i haven't done anything
wrong what are you doing she had
children there five four who had with
guns
pointed at them
i don't know in what world
that is acceptable and also how you can
possibly convince the outside world that
you're
fit to for office when that is happening
in the capital city lord knows what's
happening
way out in badikshan
again i cannot confirm
the incident you that you're alluding to
i've never heard of it
neither through our ministry of interior
nor through any reputable media
the other incident that the video that
you just showed me the ministry of
interior absolutely rejected it and
called the video fake uh it was how is
that fake
if it's fake where is the
approach the ministry of interior and
ask them how how they can came to that
conclusion
and as for
what you rightly pointed out of
terrifying women and children rousting
them from this from their sleep in the
dead of the night
it happened for 20 years in afghanistan
foreign forces
would barge into homes
kill women and children
torture them and detain them take them
to guantanamo and bagram
take them to black sites
and leave the families bomb them
and do unimaginable horror
and torture
physical and psychological harm for 20
years do you feel you're getting a a bad
rap from
the west people like me generally no no
no no i absolutely do not because uh
people in uh that that have been born
and bred in the west have a different
set of values
they see human rights differently
they see laws differently they see
people differently they have different
perspectives
of the world
and we have a different perspective and
what we're advocating is
let us understand one another
we are human beings just like you but we
are distinct just as you are disturbed
and we want to live our way of life in
our country
according to our customs and our beliefs
you've got splits within the taliban
already i'm thinking about up north when
you've got your uzbek
factions are
causing problems is this the beginning
of a split
what happened in north was a protest
that began or erupted after a
miscommunication and misunderstanding of
the situation
it's absolutely calm in in the north at
the moment there's no splits
and
as you term it if it means there's a
split within the government
we could rightly point to the protests
in the uk
does that mean there's a split in the
government
almost certainly i don't think we should
compare
does that mean there's going to be an
insurrection
absolutely not
there was a protest
people voiced their concerns
and they were addressed
simple so no possibility of
having to pull different factions who
want different things and are jostling
for power i'm thinking of how various
international politicians might be
looking at it and why do you like the
left wing and the right wing in in the
western world
does that mean there's no government
does that mean there's a struggle for
power
does that mean the country is going to
disintegrate
absolutely not
and and i i understand i mean
this has been
the
wish
and billions of dollars were poured into
trying to
split
this faction-based movement
it has not materialized until this day
and it will not materialize because this
is a representative government of the
people of afghanistan i don't know how
you can call it representative if you
haven't had any elections are you
planning elections
uh representative in this
uh in the sense
that the people of afghanistan have
chosen this government well they haven't
chosen you
the people who the foreign troops who
came and they didn't choose you they
chose they voted in elections which saw
hamad karzai being elected and ashraf
dhani being elected but they haven't
voted you in yeah i mean those those
elections are very famous or infamous
for
for a lot of things do you think they're
legitimate absolutely not okay so are
you going to have a legitimate election
uh we are the government in power we do
not plan on holding elections anytime
soon
ever
anytime soon